hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast primary HPV cervical cancer
screening supporting data and guidance
updates I am Julie O'Rourke of lab roots
and I'll be your moderator for today's
event we are delighted to bring this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots and sponsored by roche molecular
diagnostics we have a few important
announcements before we begin this
webcast is designed to be interactive
and we encourage you to ask questions
during the event you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window I'll try to
answer as many questions as we can you
can enlarge the slide window by clicking
on the screen icon in the lower right
hand corner of the slide window if you
have any technical problems viewing or
hearing this presentation click on the
support button at the top right of your
presentation window or submit your
problem through the green Q&A button
lower left I would now like to introduce
today's speaker dr. Julia angstrom
Melnick medical and scientific affairs
at roche diagnostics corporation i will
now turn it over to julia for her
presentation thank you Judy and good
afternoon everyone so we are entering a
very exciting time for cervical cancer
screening just this past year in 2014
the FDA approved the very first HPV test
for primary HPV by screening for
cervical cancer in just last month in
2015 we have the first published interim
guidance around the use of primary HPV
screening for cervical cancer so this
talk is designed to give you a little
bit of a background to these new
advances and also to provide a little
bit more information on the guidance
document as well
so the PAP was first introduced in the
1920s by dr. babes and Papanikolaou and
soon after its introduction it became
evident that this technique could
potentially reduce the burden of
cervical cancer but finding developing
cases allowing for earlier treatment and
preventing further progression countries
began introducing screening programs
based on this test in the 1950s and in
1975 ACOG published their first cervical
cancer screening recommendations which
included annual pap testing for women 18
years and older this adoption and
widespread use has led to dramatic
reduction cervical cancer rates but
despite these advancements there are
some limitations to cytology based
screening and we need to reduce cervical
cancer screening rates further here in
this slide are two audits one by the
Kaiser patient registry and one from the
Swedish national health registry looking
at the screening history of women
diagnosed with invasive cervical
carcinoma the most obvious or the most
significant need in reducing cervical
cancer rates is obviously reaching the
under screened or the non screened women
in both registries the large proportion
of women with invasive zar cervical
carcinoma either were not screened or
did not have a recent screen within the
last five years prior to the diagnosis
but we do still see cervical cancer
affecting women that have been screened
in Kaiser about thirty two percent in
Sweden about twenty four percent of
women with invasive cervical carcinoma
actually did have a recent screen and
it's a trip and it was attributed to a
failure of cytology to detect any
precursors
so it's important to understand the
limitations of the tests that we use if
we hope to improve upon them it's well
known that one of the main limitations
of cytology is its low sensitivity for
detecting high-grade disease in fact
there have been multiple attempts over
the years to improve its sensitivity
including work introducing work load
limits liquid-based cytology and
computer-assisted screening however
these attempts have done little to
impact the overall low sensitivity of
cytology or on the detection of ais and
adenocarcinomas also because cytology
relies on a subjective impression of
cellular changes in cervical cancer
precursors as they occur there is often
very low reproducibility and cytology
can identify women with advanced disease
but will not provide any insight as to
who may be at risk of developing the
distant future therefore cytology has
very limited long-term predictive value
so despite the implementation of
cytology based screening the incidence
of adenocarcinoma is increasing this
demonstrate that cytology based
screening methods are missing
adenocarcinoma and their precursor
lesions and this is most likely due to
sampling limitations and possibly an
under-representation of glandular cells
when relying on a testing method that
has very low sensitivity this type of
sampling bias has even greater
implications because they are just
simply missed
so this slide is really used to
illustrate the subjectivity of cytology
as part of the alts trial the National
Cancer Institute had about 5,000
cytology slides reread by second-sight a
pathologist each reviewer interpreted
slides slides slightly differently with
only about seventy eight percent of it
besides originally classified as normal
or nil we're actually considered
negative one reviewed by the second side
of pathology slight second side of
pathologist not not unexpected the
reproducibility of an ascus
interpretation was only about forty
three percent and it's really because
ascus is considered an equivocal
cytology interpretation but what is
surprising or what was surprising with
this study is that only about forty
seven percent of the slides originally
classified as high grade or h sill were
actually reclassified as bad upon upon
second review again highlighting the
fact that these cytology slides have
very low reproducibility between
reviewers and there's a high level of
subjectivity involved so needless to say
cytology based cervical cancer screening
has been very successful despite the
fact that the underlying cause of the
disease was not known for a very long
time in the 1970s Harold zur hausen
first hypothesized that HPV cause
cervical cancer and since then there has
been a tremendous amount of research on
this area and our knowledge has grown
exponentially in fact the 1995 the
International Agency for research on
cancer which is part of the wh 0
organization I classified HPV 16 and HPV
18 as carcinogenic and concluded the HPV
infection is a necessary
for cervical cancer today we know that
almost all cervical cancers are caused
by small number of HPV genotypes the
association between HPV and cervical
cancer is exceptionally strong for
example the odds of having cervical
cancer for women is HPV 16 positive
versus HPD negative is 435 and compare
that to the odds of a male smoker versus
a nonsmoker for developing lung cancer
which is only eight in fact we know of
all the HPV genotypes and specifically
the high risk HPV genotypes which there
are about 14 recognized only two of
those h HPV 16 and HPV 18 account for
approximately seventy percent of all
cervical cancers so with this the FDA
approved the first HPV test in 1999 and
since then cervical cancer guidelines
continue to evolve to provide
data-driven recommendation that
highlight the preferred method of
screening includes in HPV test
additional algorithms also incorporate
HPV 16 and HPV 18 genotyping due to the
its significance in its association with
cervical cancers with or even with our
evolving understanding of HPV and
despite growing awareness of cervical
cancer screening limitations cytology
based screening remains one of the most
widely used screening algorithms this
relies on cytology typically this relies
on cytology followed by an HPV test for
asking
interpretations however based on the
limitations of cytology the 2011
screening guidelines cytology screening
at a three-year interval is now only
considered an acceptable approach for to
screen women 30 to 65 it is not the
preferred method for women 21 to 29 it
still remains the only screening option
or have remained at this only screening
option due to concerns around excessive
HPV positivity in this population
however new data have since become
available to provide an approach that
makes HPV testing a viable option for
these younger women in these same 2011
screening guidelines for women 3265
incorporating an HPV test alongside the
path is now considered the preferred
method for screening the use of the HPV
test increases the sensitivity of the
initial screen and allows for extended
screening interval in this algorithm the
HPV test is used in combination with
cytology and helps drive management of
these results for a woman that tests
negative by cytology and negative by HPV
the women should be screened in five
years if there's an abnormal psychology
result of an ass kissed but the woman is
HPV negative this the same risk
stratification applies when a woman is
again should not be rescreened until
five years for ascus and HPV positive as
well as cytology results that are more
significant than ascus immediate
colposcopy is recommended or indicated
however where the HPV test
lends itself to improving screening for
these women is for the women with normal
cytology but HPV positive results these
women can either be rescreened in one
year or if a 16 and 18 genotyping is
used women with 16 and 18 positive
results should be referred to cope hasta
p those with negative 16 and 18 results
can be rescreened in one year the reason
for these new recommendations or these
the incorporation of HPV testing is that
HPV testing provides several benefits
over cytology due to its higher
sensitivity cooperating HPV DNA testing
leads to reduction in detection of cin 3
or greater or cancer in subsequent
rounds of screening which allows for a
longer safety interval HPV DNA testing
improves the texan the detection of ais
and adenocarcinoma and HPV is the first
necessary cause of a human cancer ever
identified its presence identifies women
at risk of developing cervical cancer
and can also be used to help stratify
that risk to find a women at even the
highest risk of cervical cancer and more
importantly its absence provides
reassurance of low short and long term
cervical cancer risk
in fact HPV DNA testing reduces the
incidence of invasive cervical cancer
compared to cytology here is the pooled
data from for large-scale European
screening trials the this included over
a hundred and seventy six thousand women
and over 1.2 million person years of
follow-up between two and three years
after screening there begins to be an
increase in the detection of invasive
cervical cancers and women who were
cytology negative which is the gray line
versus the women who were HPV negative
at baseline which is the blue line
overall HPV DNA based screening reduced
the cervical cancer rates by sixty to
seventy percent demonstrating that when
compared to cytology based screening HPV
DNA testing offers greater safety and
reduces long-term incidence of cervical
cancer it should be noted that the
benefit of a combined cytology and HPV
testing is predominantly due to the
negative predictive value of HPV test as
a risk is not dramatically improved when
the two are combined but when it comes
to the risk of cervical cancer there
really is no statistical difference HPV
testing alone provides the same
reassurance against cervical cancer as a
co test
so with this in 2014 the FDA approved
the first HPV DNA test for primary HPV
screening indication based on the
improved safety of the strategy over
cytology based screening in response
following review of the FDA submission
data and finding some newly published
large-scale studies SGO and a sccp
jointly published interim guidance for
the use of primary HPV screening this
guidance document affirmed that primary
HPV screening is an option for women 25
years and older so this is the algorithm
that was describing the guidance
document for women 25 years and older
and HPV and HPV test that's FDA approved
for a primary screening indication will
be used in conjunction with HPV 16 and
18 genotyping this not only relies on
the more sensitive and non subjective
test of the first line test but also
incorporates immediate risk
stratification women that are test the
test HP be negative are at an extremely
low risk of having cervical pre-cancer
both at the time of screening screening
and also within the screening interval
so they should not be rescreened sooner
than three years women positive for 16
and 18 actually those women at the
highest risk of having an underlying
precancerous lesion or developing a
cervical precancerous lesion within a
short period of time so these women
should be referred for immediate
colposcopy for additional follow-up
women HPV positive but negative for HPV
16 and eight
teen are at a much lower risk than those
that are 16 and 18 positive but these
women are actually not without risk
cytology is then used to triage these
results to identify which women which
women in this subset have detectable
cellular changes that would warrant
immediate colposcopy so only if a woman
is positive for the 12 other high-risk
genotypes sown on 16 and 18 and have
abnormal psychology should they be
should she be referred to colposcopy if
she does not have any detectable
cellular changes she should be
rescreened in a year so the guidance
document was developed based on an
extensive literature and data review so
not only the data that led to the F the
FDA submission data but also 11
additional large-scale studies both in
the US and outside of the US in combined
representatives from seven different
professional societies for their expert
opinions they determined that primary
HPV screening is an alternative to
current cervical screening methods due
to equivalent or superior effectiveness
a negative high-risk HPV test provides
greater reassurance of low seeing
through your greater risk than a
negative cytology result and they also
said that primary HIV screening can
include women 25 to 29 this is really
because of the higher proportion of
high-grade disease in this in this
subset of women and also how cytology
performs in detecting these cervical
pre-cancer zeeeee they also stated very
clearly that only an fda-approved assay
with specific primary HPV screening
indication should be used
that's really because although there are
several HPV assays that are currently
fda-approved only one hat has this
specific indication in all of these
assays very us have slight variations in
their performance characteristics and so
no assumption should be made that these
are equivalent assays so the
effectiveness of primary HPV screening
is mainly determined by their risks
associated with the negative screening
result risk of cin 3 or greater over 3
years following a negative HPV test at
baseline just the the lower curve in
blue is half that following a negative
PAP result a baseline which is the upper
curve in in grey as expected the rise in
the slope is much more pronounced
following a negative baseline pap
results than a negative HPV result and
this really highlight that long-term
risk assessment is limited when only
assessing current cell abnormalities so
there's a much greater level of safety
following a negative HPV result than a
negative cytology result and these
findings from Athena were also mirrored
across other large-scale studies so this
is a table taken from the new interim
guidance document that was that were
published in 2015 or just last month and
across all these studies a negative HPV
test resulted in at least half the three
and five-year risk of both see 93 and
greater and cervical cancer than
cytology
additionally HPV 16 and 18 genotyping
provides greater risk stratification not
only identifying women at that with the
highest probability of having an
underlying high-grade lesion at baseline
but also over the screening interval in
Athena one in four women with a baseline
HPV positive results developed CI and
three within three years although lower
than hpv-16 positive women HPV 18
positive women were still a
statistically higher risk of developing
seeing three or greater than those
positive for the 12 other high-risk HPV
types exceeding ten percent risk for cin
3 within three years women testing
positive for the 12 other high-risk HPV
types or at a substantially lower risk
of cin 3 or greater reaching about 5%
are within three years so whereas HPV
status will predict which women are
essentially free from risk HPV
genotyping more accurately predicts
which were men will subsequently develop
high grade cervical cancer precursors
this risk stratification better assesses
of women's need for immediate colposcopy
and helps balance rates of referral to
the disease cases detected as we try to
simplify and improve how we screen by
introducing primary HPV screening a
consideration must be made as to when to
initiate this the screening the 2011 us
screening guidelines did not recommend
HPV testing for women 25 to 29 years of
age unless it's used as a reflex to ask
us pap this is largely due to the fact
that HPV infections are very common and
typically transient in this age group
however in the recent interim guidance
the professional societies did
acknowledge there's a high burden of
seeing three in this age group and
cytology which is a standard of care
performs poorly in this population but
because these do recommendations are a
departure from the previous guidelines
there are a few questions that we really
should address one is why include women
25 to 29 how is high prevalence of high
risk HPV and the referrals to colposcopy
balanced in this age group and what
considerations should be made around
regression of high-grade disease in
young women so first let's look at the
incidence of cervical cancer but age
group in the US data from the National
Cancer Institute's dear tumor registry
shows that a sharp rise in the incidence
of invasive cervical cancer occurs
between the age of 25 to 34 years of age
cervical cancer is unique or cervical
cancer screening is unique in the fact
that we detect and manage cervical
cancer precursors before cervical cancer
develops so the ultimate goal of
cervical cancer screening is not to
detect cancer but to prevent the
diagnosis of cervical cancer all
together so this suggests that
initiation of screening should ideally
occur during the sharp increase in
cervical cancer incidence just prior to
the peak if we want to reduce their
subsequent diagnoses in practice we
actually do screen women over the age of
21 but the question really is are we
screening effectively
so in Athena which is a large US based
registration on trial referenced in the
guidance document a third of all
identified cervical pre-cancer Xin women
25 years of age and older were found in
women 25 to 29 years of age to put this
into perspective let's take a look at
the distribution of these cases based on
the number of women actually represented
within each age group what we can see
that there is actually more high-grade
disease in the six thousand six hundred
forty seven women in this five-year age
group of 25 to 29 than any other age
group this demonstrates that the highest
burden of disease is actually in women
25 to 29 so this youngest age group and
keep in mind this age range is also
right at the start of the sharp incline
and cervical cancer diagnosis so the
question is are are we effective in
current screening practices so we just
saw that there is a high burden of
disease in women 25 to 29 and keep in
mind women 30 years and older according
to the 2011 screening guidelines have a
safety net built in so these women are
our Co tested so they have both an HPV
test and a psychology test so although
cytology may not detect all the cervical
pre-cancer that combined HPV test will
help add to that sensitivity of the
cytology results but for women 25 to 29
with the highest burden of disease
cytology up to this point has been the
only option and cytology failed to
detect more than 50
six percent of the cervical pre-cancer
this is more than any other grade age
group and in an age range that has the
highest burden of pre-cancer it suggests
the current screening with cytology is
inadequate in identifying underlying cin
3 or greater lesions it simply is not
sensitive enough but if we simplify but
if we simply screen with HPV effectively
increasing sensitivity a large
proportion of women will be referred for
follow-up testing as expected HPV
positivity is at the highest and the
youngest age group and declines with age
in Athena the percent of women 25 to 29
there were hpv-positive was about twenty
one percent so how can we balances high
prevalence of high-risk HPV una
referrals to colposcopy in this age
group one way to reduce the immediate
referrals is to focus on the group of
women that are at the highest risk of
cervical cancer and risk of cervical
pre-cancer and these are the women there
HPV 16 and or HPV 18 positive in Athena
only about seven percent of women 25 to
29 were positive for one of these two
genotypes and the proportion of women 25
to 29 that were HPV or h16 or HPV 18
positive is actually much smaller than
the number with abnormal psychology by
simply using HPV 16 and 18 genotyping
for women 25 to 29 the smallest group of
women with the highest association of
cervical pre-cancer would be referred to
for media colposcopy and with this shift
in screening strategy for women 25 to 29
look how much better we can do we could
increase
the effectiveness of screening by
detecting thirty percent more ce9 for
your greater cases than by cytology and
that's just for HPV 16 and 18 positive
cases by incorporating the 12 other
high-risk HPV types with a path triage
we can improve the detection of cin 3 or
greater even further it's important to
note that high-grade disease found in
young women is more likely associated
with HPV 16 than any other genotype and
the mean age for HPV 16 positive see 93
or greater lesions is below the age of
30 hpv16 positive cin 3 was most
commonly diagnosed in younger women
versus older women further highlighting
the effectiveness of genotyping and
screening younger women in fact even in
the very youngest age group so those
women 13 to 24 which presumably have the
overall highest clearance rates HPV 16
and 18 positive lesions were less likely
to regress the non HPV 16 and 18 but we
can even take this discussion a step
further and we can look at the overall
effectiveness of very very screening
methods including women 25 to 29 so in
discussions of cervical cancer screening
and screening modalities in the 2011
cervical cancer screening guidelines
they acknowledge that the benefit of
screening should be balanced against the
potential harms with the total number of
co pasta peas serving as a surrogate
measure for home and benefits being the
overall detection of cin 3 or greater
lesions the Athena study provides an
opportunity to evaluate both
benefit and potential harms of screening
on various combinations of cytology
high-risk HPV testing and genotyping for
HPV 16 and 18 are used to develop a
screening algorithm for women 25 years
Mulder Chris implicitly sake the focus
will be on three algorithms supported by
us screening guidelines the first is
cytology which relies on HPV testing to
triage ask its results for women 25
years and older the second is the co
testing strategy relying on a one-year
co test rescreen for women with normal
cytology and HPV positive results keep
in mind that this co testing strategy is
only for women 30 years and older the
third is a primary HPV screening
algorithm which is now supported by sgo
and a sccp as a screening option in
these latest interim guidance because
the analysis evaluate the performance in
two different age groups women 25 years
and older and women 30 years and older
certain modifications to the co test and
screening algorithm must be considered
for women 25 and older it's actually
going to be a hybrid strategy and it
combines a cytology method for women 25
to 29 combined with the co testing
algorithm for women 30 years and older
for women 30 years and older this hybrid
strategy is actually going to be more of
a co testing strategy or solely co
testing so when comparing the
effectiveness or the efficiency of the
screening methods we look at the number
of cin three cases detected and the
number of co pasta peas performed and
more specifically we're looking
the number of colposcopy there needed to
be performed for each CI and three case
detected for women 25 years and older
primary HPV screaming detected nearly
forty percent more cin 3 or greater
lesions at baseline than either of the
two other two screening modalities the
superior performance actually extended
over the three years with greater than
twenty percent more CI and 3 or greater
lesions detective in the hybrid strategy
and sixty-four percent more than
cytology for women 25 years and older
for women 30 years and older primary HPV
screaming detective nearly thirty
percent more cin through your greater at
baseline than either of the other two
screening methods by year three detected
fifty percent more cin 3 or greater
cases and cytology and the co testing
method nearly caught up but keep in mind
that many of these subsequent cases may
remain undetected if a loss to follow-up
is a concern in various clinical
practices although higher than cytology
the number of copas capiz performed per
identified case of c 9 3 or greater for
primary HPV screening was nearly
identical to the hybrid strategy and
also the co testing strategy for both
age groups
but how does Peregrine HPV perform a
primary screening perform in women 25 to
29 by extending HPV primary screening
down to age 25 from 30 a hundred and two
additional CI and through your greater
cases are detected versus only 51 for
cytology that's X that's exactly twice
the number of cin three cases are
detected by primary HP be screening then
would be detected by cytology with this
increase in sensitivity the number of
close pasta peas would all naturally
also increase by including women 25 to
29 an additional 1247 colposcopy s will
be performed with primary HPV screening
however this is actually less than twice
the number of additional colposcopy
performed following cytology this means
that the higher proportional gain in cin
through your greater sensitivity for
women 25 to 29 actually makes the
colposcopy is performed with following
the primary HPV screening algorithm more
efficient in other words HPV primary
screaming identifies more cin 3 or
greater than cytology while requiring
fewer colposcopy / disease case detected
for women 25 to 29 proving the HPV
primary screening is the most effective
screening strategy for this age group in
a similar vein if we add cytology
testing for women 25 to 29 to the co
testing hybrid strategy the number of
colposcopy is needed to detect each cin
3 or greater case actually shifts
compared to primer HPV screening and
actually becomes less efficient this is
mainly due to the significantly fewer
cases of cin 3 or
rader cases detected one relying on
cytology so as we try to improve how we
screen by introducing primer HPV
screening a consideration must be made
as to when to initiate this there's a
high burden of CA and 3 or greater in
women 25 to 29 which is the current and
the current standard of care which is
cytology testing really performed out
poorly in this population HPV testing
increases the sensitivity and detection
of these high-grade lesions and
strategies are relying on HPV 16 and 18
genotyping as well as cytology can
effectively stratify risk and limit the
overall referrals to cope hasta p rates
of kalpas copies is not an accurate
measure of the potential harms of
screening as risks associated with this
procedure and treatments accompanying
these may have been overstated and it's
important to consider that there must be
a threshold for which a colposcopy is
acceptable even for women 25 to 29 it
may be that the potential discomfort and
anxiety associated with a follow-up
procedure is tolerated if the
alternative is a missed precancerous
lesion it's clear that cervical cytology
appears to have reached the point where
it alone is unable to do reduce cervical
cancer rates further the benefits of
primary HPV screening include increased
detection of cervical cancer precursors
especially for women 25 to 29 the best
balance of benefits and harms using HPV
testing as a first-line primary screen
the triage started
strategy that include integrated HPV 16
and 18 genotyping as well as cytology of
the 12 other high-risk HPV genotypes
primary HPV testing is now an
alternative option to current cytology
based screening methods due to
equivalent or superior performance and
with that I want to thank you all for
your attention I will turn it back to
Judy to answer some of the questions I
see the question tab flashing so I want
to try and address as many as I can
within a lot of time thank you for that
informative presentation before we get
started on the question and answer
session I would like to remind our
audience how to submit questions you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window we'll
try to answer as many questions you can
in our first question is what about
testing for low-risk genotypes sure
actually get this question quite quite a
bit so low risk HPV genotypes or I
should say so HPV encompasses many many
different types of this virus over a
hundred have been identified only 14
have actually been linked to cervical
cancer and these are considered a
high-risk HPV genotypes low risk HPV
genotypes can cause cellular changes and
abnormalities that are kind of
considered high grade but they have
never been demonstrated to them cross
that threshold into invasive cervical
cancer so there really is no clinical
utility for detecting low risk HPV
genotypes so it's also important to have
an HPV test that doesn't have any cross
reactivity
or that inadvertently detect these
genotypes again because there is no
clinical indication for it k our next
question does the FDA labeling requires
cytology as a reflex for all HPV
positive or just non 1618 results sure
so the FDA approval as well as the
guidance document stipulate that HPV 16
and 18 women are it is sufficiently high
enough risk that they should be referred
immediately to colposcopy regardless of
what their cytology results are women
that are 12 other high-risk HPV
genotyping but negative 4 16 and 18 they
are at risk for cervical cervical
pre-cancer but their risk is
significantly lower than the other two
genotypes like I mentioned these women
are not free from risk entirely so
cytology is then used to really help
stratify that risk a little bit better
or kind of fine tune that risk a little
bit more HPV positivity is actually can
be very high in certain populations so
we do not want to send every single
woman with an HPV positive result to
colposcopy but rather the women at the
highest risk are the ones should that
should be followed and potentially
managed at that time
next question is did Roche fund the
study that was the basis for HPV primary
screening ah yes or no uh so roast infa
fund Athena study this was rochas
clinical trial for the kobus HPV test so
that trial and the data that that
culminated from that trial was submitted
to the FDA for a review that included a
potential for the co bus test to be used
as a frontline primary HPV screening the
FDA reviewed that data alongside a a
panel of experts of medical with their
medical device panel and it reviewed
that data for safety and effectiveness
and they independent dependently then
gave a stamp of approval based on that
review to the test the guidance document
published by SGL na is DCP reviewed that
data independently as well but they also
utilized additional studies large-scale
studies both from the US and ex us so a
total of eleven additional references to
make their recommendation and to kind of
evaluate the utility of primary HPV
screening so in some respect yes we
funded one small little subset of this
bigger scope of primary HPV screening
but Roche did not influence the guidance
document in any way and again the FDA
works independently to review all tests
for safety and effectiveness
what percentage of cin 3 plus are missed
by HPV primary with Roche in your
clinical trial so that's going back to
looking at the safety of a negative HPV
test and this is really evaluated for
any test what we look at or how these
trials are the clinic how this
particular clinical trial is designed
Athena was to really test to really
stress the test to its full potential or
really make sure that we were detecting
any possible case that could be
mystified by the actual test itself so
women receive a colposcopy regardless of
for any abnormal result whether or not
be a cytology abnormal or h or HPV
positive result those women received
colposcopy and biopsies and we also
performed an exit colposcopy so any
woman who did not have disease found
during the three-year follow-up were
then given an exit colposcopy at the
time of exit again to just assess
whether or not there were any any
residual disease was missed so the the
end point to that or the three-year risk
of a negative Kobus HPV test was three
point point three four percent from the
clinical trial and that's compared to a
negative PAP in that three-year span was
about point seven eight percent so again
the risks of a negative HPV test was was
half that of a negative cytology result
do you know if types HPV 16 18 or more
virulent than other types of HPV or are
they just more prevalent compared to
other types sure so HPV 16 and 18 are
actually not the most prevalent HPV
genotypes so I kind of showed that the
prevalence rates of HPV and Athena's
trial so just looking at the 25 to 29 s
for example 21 percent of women 25 to 29
were positive for HPV but HPV 16 and 18
only accounted for seven percent of
those positive cases so that's a third
of all the HPV positives so there are
not the most prevalent as an entity they
are the most virulent and by variant I
mean that they are highly persistent
meaning an infection within HPV 16 or 18
is less likely to clear or regress they
are more likely to progress so actually
increase in severity with time and with
that they are in the timeframe for that
progression or that shift to more severe
cases and actually much shorter than
than all the other genotypes so they are
absolutely the most virulent HPV 18 is
also very unique because it has a very
high proportion its accounts for a very
high proportion of adenocarcinomas so
that's adds to its significance for
genotyping and cervical cancer screening
okay please clarify the future risk of
cancer with co test versus a versus HPV
primary at three years is lower engaged
study and in fact statistically
significant according to the publication
you said there is no difference is that
correct um so for CI in three icim too
there's a difference but for cervical
cancer incidence there is no difference
and that was because the error bars
overlap that is not a statistically
significant difference so it's very
clear on distinguishing that from the
other keep in mind we are the the
utility of cervical cancer screening is
really to minimize their risk or the
development of cervical cancer and when
to test combined has really no
statistical significance over subsequent
cancer diagnosis that's where that plays
in a role your next question is a
two-part question since the data
demonstrates high sensitivity for young
women should older women be excluded for
this test and the second part is when
detecting HR HPV in young women what is
the intervention following colposcopy
confirmation lesion resection or
cervical reception so women all over the
age of 30 should be screened with
cytology and HPV again to assess the
risks these women have a much higher in
overall incidence of cervical cancer and
actually older women and I use the term
older very loosely are the risk of
cervical cancer
that may not necessarily be 16 and 18
positive so there's absolutely a utility
for screening women older than older
than just the small young population and
I think I tap the second half of that
question and I know it had something to
do with management strategies if that's
ok I'm going to answer that with with
whoever asked that specifically because
I have to go back and read it ok I
believe we have time for one more
question so it will be what percentage
of patients with HPV 16 18 progressed to
see I n 2 plus any difference between 16
and 18 progression rates um yeah so
there's absolutely a difference in
progression rates and I forgive me if I
don't know those rates right off the top
of my head I can definitely follow up
with that the person who asked this
question us HPV 16 and 18 does progress
more rapidly and more frequently than
non HPV 16 and 18 positive women there's
also studies that demonstrate that HPV
16 infections tend to progress most much
more readily in women younger than h 30
than those that are older than 30 but I
will follow up with you to get a little
bit more clarification on that and I
think duty indicated that this was the
last question for those questions that
did not answer and those questions that
I promise to follow up you will I will
address each one of them I'm sorry we
couldn't get to every single one with it
a lot of time but I do want to thank you
all for joining us
and it's been a pleasure and again I
thank you unfortunately we are out of
time I want to thank the audience for
their interesting questions and
participation in today's event any
questions not addressed live during a
lot of time will be addressed by the
speaker via the contact information you
provided at the time of registration for
more information we would like to invite
you to visit w wh pv 16 and 18 com i
would also like to thank our sponsor
roche molecular diagnostics for making
today's educational webcast possible
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through May tenth
you'll receive an email from lab roots
alerting you when this webcast will be
available for replay we invite you to
forward that announcement to your
colleagues Samantha miss today's live
event see you next time goodbye